our next guest says don't be fooled by
Bernie's money bombs Sanders 2020 is
going nowhere
here with more is host of the Michael
Noel's show Michael knows Michael I
guess you're not feeling the Bern I'm
not feeling the Bern I think people have
amnesia they're forgetting that 12 years
ago Ron Paul
we raised exactly the same amount of
money in exactly the same amount of time
six million dollars in 24 hours as you
will recall Ron Paul never won the GOP
presidential nomination Bernie Sanders
will not win the Democrat nomination the
problem for Bernie is that he's a victim
of his own success Bernie Sanders has so
successfully radicalized the Democrat
Party brought it over to the extreme
left had it redefine itself along
socialist lines that now the question is
if every other candidate in the field is
spouting the same sort of things that
Bernie Sanders does then why would
anybody vote for Bernie Sanders
especially today in a Democrat Party
that is obsessed with identity politics
if you've got the same radicalism from
everybody why would you vote for the
fairly ancient old white guy so Michael
that's the big question every candidate
is going to try and define themselves
Bernie Sanders is the original socialist
you have people like Kamala Harris thing
I'm not a Democratic Socialist but the
question now is where is Bernie Sanders
Lane the Fox News poll recently showed
when you look at socialism versus
capitalism 57% have a favorability a
favorable opinion of capitalism and just
25% have a favorable opinion of
socialism so can Bernie Sanders really
win such as a primary but a general
election when the majority of the
country is staunchly against what he's
proposing
fortunately for Democrats the party is
so corrupt that they'll probably just
rig it again and keep Bernie Sanders out
of election what really helped Bernie in
2016 is that he was running as the anti
Hillary vote so he opposed Hillary
Clinton young to all of her empty
promises and all of her wickedness but
today of course there are so many other
options if he makes it through those
numbers seem favorable the majority of
the country is not yet socialist but
when you look at the Democrat Bay
and when you look especially at
Millennials the numbers really start to
turn
socialism is resurgent this is a great
testament to Bernie Sanders is
regressive politics and regressive
ideology but here in the general
election I think it's a loser for
Democrats I don't know here's a problem
with your argument michael metz this
stators 123 primaries and caucuses last
go-around and he was pretty much robbed
of it because of the DNC people are
still anti-establishment so why do you
say he won't at least give every other
person in this giant field a run for
their money because he was running
against one of the most despised
candidates in all of American history
and a perfect mediocrity in Martin
O'Malley
today we have Kamala Harris Joe Biden so
many other far better candidates who
will be speaking to the same people that
Bernie does I think they'll have much
more success oh Michael no I always
appreciate your perspective thank you
thanks Michael good to see it